the movie opens up as a monk named
Master Tang is on a journey to India to
obtain the holy scriptures and bring
them to China he is accompanied by his
disciples the Monkey King Sun Wukong
baji and Shah on their Journey they have
passed several tests but this one will
be the toughest one they have come
across during their Journey they travel
across a river by boat everything seems
to be going fine but suddenly a river
monster emerges out of nowhere and
attacks them the group tries their best
to defend themselves but to no avail as
they are about to be eaten alive a
mysterious portal appears out of nowhere
and swallows the group when they reach
the other side of the portal they begin
to fall at a very high speed as they
continue their Free Fall Master Tag
notices a beautiful woman and it appears
as if he has fallen in love at first
sight
[Music]
but before the group can decipher their
location the beautiful woman approaches
them and inquires if their Men Tang who
at this point is completely smitten
responds yes but the woman walks away
with only a smile shortly after she
arrives at a large Kingdom which is
inhabited by only women from the
ministers to the workers doctors to the
Librarians everyone is female moreover
the beautiful woman is revealed to be
the queen of the Kingdom which they
refer to as woman land
women are more creative than that she
approaches her servants and tells them
about the men she encountered but none
of them believe her it appears as if the
kingdom has been isolated from the outer
world and hence no one has ever seen a
man in their lifetime the queen
continues telling her servants that she
came across some men but instead of
believing her they begin to suspect that
she has become ill following that they
take out an ancestral book which states
that men are poisonous however its
explanation is incomplete because some
parts of the book are missing just then
the Kingdom's Empress walks in and
confronts everyone she is the one who
raised the queen and is in charge of the
entire place when she hears the rumors
that some men have invaded their sacred
sanctity she orders her girls to find
them on the other hand Master Tang
Wukong and Shaw are looking for
directions in the forest while baji
comes across a treasure a group of girls
he spies on them bathing in the river
because no movie like this would ever be
complete without a bathing in the river
scene and he becomes excited In the Heat
of the Moment he also transfers forms
himself into a masculine man and
approaches them however the girls
capture and punish him causing him to
revert to his original Avatar meanwhile
Wukong tang and Shah are apprehended by
a group of female soldiers Master Tang
forbids his disciples from using any
violence and tries to Defuse The
Situation peacefully but the enraged
women take them to their Kingdom to
receive punishment this is when they
finally realize that they have entered
the kingdom of women a kingdom where men
do not exist after reaching the
Kingdom's Palace they meet the woman
they met before and realize that she's
actually the queen then comes an elderly
woman who displays an ancestral book in
which a monk a monkey a pig and a
blue-skinned Bruiser are mentioned in
the book it turns out that the arrival
of the Monk and his disciples had
already been predicted based on the
prediction this would bring destruction
to this Kingdom as soon as the females
hear this pressure comes from various
parties especially from the empress to
sentence the men to death the queen also
agrees but before that she wants to
interrogate them first although hesitant
the empress agrees and the men are
imprisoned for one night inside the
palace before the execution day at this
stage Wukong who possesses superhuman
strength can easily fight the women off
and help his friends however when he
remembers Master Tang's advice to
refrain from violence he decides to
comply with the situation the same night
however Master Tang agrees to do a
prison break Wukong breaks the prison
door allowing them all to flee at the
same time the queen and her servants
arrive at the prison for interrogation
but they are accidentally knocked out by
the man once outside the men try to fly
back to their world but it turns out
that this kingdom is protected by an
enchanted barrier that even the great
Wukong himself can't penetrate realizing
that there is no escaping the place
Wukong suggests that they speak to the
queen as she is the only one who can
help them Master tang and the others
also agree and they return back to the
prison after a while the queen and her
servants regain Consciousness and make
their way to the prison the queen
decides to question the four
individually so she questions Tang while
the other servants interrogate the
remaining three during the interrogation
the queen confesses that she is
attracted to Tang but the latter claims
that he's a monk and cannot love the
queen he also shares that his sole goal
of traveling to the West is so that he
can obtain the holy scriptures with
which he can rid the world of its
sufferings he then hands her a travel
log containing all of his thoughts and
insights as the two start getting
friendly Wukong interrupts them and
inquires about the way out and the queen
promises to help them just then the
empress arrives at the prison and
announces that the men will be executed
the following day the next day the men
are tied with ropes and preparations for
their execution are underway a few
moments later the queen arrives dressed
as a soldier it turns out that she has
planned everything for their escape she
informs the men that she has replaced
the sharp Arrows with toy ones and all
they have to do is fake their deaths the
men agree and the execution Begins the
empress orders her soldiers to shoot the
man at first Shaw is shot and he
pretends to be dead brilliantly however
when it's tangs turn he struggles to act
as he has been taught to never deceive
others seeing this Shaw cleverly throws
a stone at him knocking him out then
Wukong is shot but during baji's turn
the empress orders the soldiers to
change the arrows being a man in this
Kingdom alone is a crime but being an
ugly one is an even bigger crime Jesus
the writer of this has some priorities
to sort out as a result he is attacked
with multiple arrows however since baji
is a demigod himself he won't die that
easily after completing the execution
ceremony the empress orders their bodies
to be thrown away at this point
everything is going according to the
plan of the queen she manages to bring
them to a safe place which turns out to
be a very sacred place in the women's
Kingdom right then the queen reveals
that even she herself doesn't know how
to get out of this Kingdom as for
centuries no one has ever tried to get
out of this Kingdom but she believes
that the missing fragment from The
ancestral book May provide an answer
hearing this Wukong deduces that the
missing page of the book is hidden
somewhere around this sacred place so
they all begin to search for it after a
bit of looking around Wukong discovers
the paper and gives it to his master
Kang goes through the paper and
discovers that the only way to leave the
woman Land Is by understanding the
meaning of love as a monk Tang admits
that he doesn't know much about love but
just then one of the servants reveals
that she once heard about a love story
in the Kingdom of women rumor says that
there was one girl who was very curious
about what lies beyond the realm of
women mysteriously she then had a
relationship with a water boy from the
outside world because they were from
different worlds they were unable to
meet in person and could only meet
telepathically unfortunately not much is
known about the ending of their love
story hopefully they discovered Face
Time suddenly Tang sha and baji scream
in agony as their stomachs swell the
queen congratulates them and reveals
that they drank water from the river of
the Sacred place the water has a magical
power those who drink it will get
pregnant moreover it will only take nine
days to give birth after the pregnancy
being the only one who didn't get
pregnant Wukong is tasked to find a
solution given the fact that they are
men it will be very difficult to give
birth so Wukong doesn't have much time
left to save them fortunately a servant
informs them of a woman's location who
possesses the abortion water Wukong
rushes to the said woman but finds out
that the process of making abortion
water takes at least 100 years what the
hell is going on in this movie however
when Wukong starts pleading the woman
reveals that there is a shorter process
too she asks Wukong to touch her heart
with true love and make her shed tears
those tears will be the abortion water
that he wants however Wukong doesn't
understand anything about love as he's
never been with a woman before all he
knows is the care and love Master Tang
has shown him Wukong starts narrating
that long ago he was a very chaotic
person until Master Tang accepted him as
a disciple from that day onwards he
promised to never let his master down
and do whatever it takes to protect him
unexpectedly the woman considers the
story to be a story of true love and
sheds her tears after retrieving the
tears Wukong bails on her immediately
and rushes back to his people on the
other hand tank still hasn't come to
terms that he will be giving birth to a
baby however the queen tries to explain
that the process is not a bad thing
after all she also mentions that
performing an abortion is the same as
killing hearing all this Kang slowly
starts to accept the reality that this
movie has a political agenda and decides
to give birth meanwhile Wukong arrives
with the abortion water but tang and the
other men share their decision to give
birth hearing this Wukong is enraged as
he believes that having a child will
distract Tang from his goal so he
freezes them all and forces them to
drink the abortion water the water
reacts fast causing their stomachs to
revert back to their normal selves
however Tang appears to be displeased to
calm himself down he goes away and
copies the words from the scriptures on
the ground ever since he was a kid he
has been using this technique to calm
himself the queen also joins him and
they both start writing stuff
Unfortunately they are so caught up in
the activity that they reach very far
and the empress spots them she
immediately orders her soldiers to
arrest Tang despite the queen begging
her not to do so but instead of being
imprisoned Tang is taken to the seashore
the coast is known as the Endless Sea
where if a person sails he or she will
never return shortly after while Tang is
being sailed away the queen arrives on
her deer and jumps into his boat in no
time the boat goes far off the beach and
thick fog covers their surroundings now
it seems as if they have lost their way
as nothing is visible meanwhile the
empress is devastated because she
believes that the woman land will be
destroyed without the queen she
immediately goes to Wukong and tells him
what happened as Wukong tries to
understand the gravity of the situation
the empress Falls to her knees and begs
him to Save the Queen this finally
convinces Wukong and he sets out to find
the sailing Duo however this sea is
named the Endless Sea for a reason even
with the magical eye Wukong can't manage
to find them elsewhere tang and the
queen becomes stranded in the middle of
the sea the Mist has disappeared but as
far as their eyes can see there is only
ocean although it hasn't been long since
they entered the sea it has felt like
ages for them the queen becomes thirsty
so she decides to drink the sea water
but Tang stops her claiming that it will
make her even more thirsty eventually
tank sincerely offers his flesh to be
eaten by the queen this makes the queen
very emotional but she refuses the offer
and prefers to face all the challenges
together besides that's disgusting after
a while a massive storm hits the sea but
the couple somehow manages to survive
and spend the night after the hurricane
passes their boat finally touches the
mainland it turns out this is what was
meant in the prophecy that only true
love can open the exit gates of the
female Kingdom the love shown by both of
them has caused a giant gate to appear
in the middle of the sea this is spotted
by Wukong and the rest and they manage
to find their Master immediately they
invite Tang to leave the place but Tang
instead turns to the queen and invites
her to go together after a bit of
discussion the men enter the gate but
when the queen tries to step in she is
stopped by by the enchanted barrier
indicating that she is not permitted to
leave womanland when she tries to force
her way through the barrier woman land
and its inhabitants begin to transform
into stone the queen herself begins
transforming into stone fortunately Tang
quickly grabs her and returns her back
to normalcy however she collapses and
loses Consciousness in the next scene
The Waterboy also notices the gate and
quickly swims to womanland where his
partner lives elsewhere as the empress
is caring for the queen she is reminded
of the past several years ago the
previous Queen handed over a child to
the empress claiming that the child has
the bloodline of woman land the previous
Queen also asked the empress to raise
the child the best possible way she can
it is then revealed that The Girl Who
Fell In Love With The Waterboy was none
other than the empress herself however
because she was tasked with taking care
of the child she had to give up her love
for him meanwhile Tang decides to stay
in woman land a little longer until the
queen is fully recovered right then he
is approached by the goddess of Mercy
who enlightens him regarding the matter
she informs him that he must choose
between these two to love one person or
all sentient beings at the end of the
conversation she's confident that Tang
will make the correct decision
afterwards he returns to the Palace
where the entire kingdom is performing a
ritual for the Queen's Health as
everyone is praying The Waterboy
suddenly arrives and surprises the
empress he has waited for 20 years for
this moment and expresses his love for
her the empress is touched by this but
she knows where her Destiny lies that is
to guide the queen to lead the kingdom
hence she refuses to rekindle their
relationship oof The Waterboy deserved
better this enrages The Waterboy and as
a result he decides to destroy the
kingdom oh I guess he didn't deserve
better at first he kidnaps Tang into the
queen but the amazing Monkey King
immediately saves them when his first
attempt fails The Waterboy transforms
into a devil and starts attacking the
kingdom Wukong Shah and baji team up to
stop him but all in vain soon The
Waterboy transforms into an even bigger
form and and begins drowning the kingdom
this destroys woman land and all the
women fall into the sea witnessing such
Devastation Master Tang who is also
drowning enters a meditation State and
prays to Lord Buddha to save the people
surprisingly the Lord hears his prayers
and appears he saves the drowning women
and punishes The Waterboy for his
misdeeds finally the storm passes by and
life and woman land becomes normal again
after a lot of Enlightenment Master Tang
has finally made up his mind to carry
out his duty and continue his mission
with a heavy heart the queen accepts his
decision and also accepts her Destiny to
lead this women's Kingdom finally the
four men wave a final goodbye to the
queen and set off on their Journey to
the West hoping to find the holy
scriptures subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching